is a teacher who's just gone viral for
uh telling white people to stop
encouraging their daughters to be
mothers please stop gassing your white
daughters up to be
mothers stop telling them that it is
their Destiny and their Birthright to
one day be a mother and they will one
day be a
parent but they want to quot but stop
making them feel like that's their
Birthright because they often grow up
feeling entitled to
children and if they can't have their
own children they will be entitled to
take someone else's child why is it that
he's telling white women not to want to
be mothers oh because they sometimes
then if they cannot have biological
children adopt non-white babies what
this guy's saying is that he would
rather non-white children be orphans
than be raised by white people that's
how much that guy hates white people